In the coming weeks and months ahead,
you're gonna hear a lot more
announcements happening on this site.
About new users, new activities, and
things that will bring vitality
to the site and its neighborhood.
And we're here today to
welcome those new neighbors,
to generate new economies, and to look
ahead to the rebirth of this place.
>> This site has been vacant for
20 plus years and for
the neighborhood when you constantly
heard, we're coming, this is happening,
this is happening, and nothing was really
happening, and we turn the momentum.
We have new storefronts, we have a new
library, we have a new school and then
you get announcements on the side knowing
that, hey, something's gonna happen and
it's not just for four or five people,
it's for our entire community.
>> There's so much that I have
learned in this community.
And Hazelwood Green means a lot
in our vision going forward.
>> There's a lot of excitement
about what could be in Hazelwood.
So we wanna make sure that
the people who have lived here for
years, are able to stay here and
benefit from all development that comes.
>> I wanna see every person being able
to access the absolute highest level
of education, so
that they can compete around the world.
>> This community is an opportunity
to create very positive
development experience.
Now finally, some of those plans have
an opportunity to come to fruition.
>> When you're looking at a new site with
all types of jobs that are going to be
happening, we have to ensure
that Hazelwood residents have
not only a stake at the table,
but also have a job.
>> The conversation that we've had
from the very beginning is that
the Hazelwood Green site not be isolated
from Hazelwood, but be integrated.
>> I want Hazelwood to be
a world class community.
>> We're not saying this is the site and
that's the neighborhood, no,
this is all blended together.
And everybody in the neighborhood
is welcome down here and
every business down here is
welcome in the neighborhood.
[MUSIC]